Hey, Thoughty2 here.
One of the greatest myths of childhood is that
when we grow up, we’ll finally be in charge.
But while it’s true that reaching adulthood
means you get to choose our own bedtime and
eat pizza for dinner every night, the idea
that we suddenly become masters of our own
destinies is simply an illusion - whether it’s
paying taxes or staying at home during lockdown,
sometimes we all have to do things we don’t
want to do. Still, aside from the rules and
regulations passed down by the government,
our employers, (...and our partners),
we like to believe that our decisions
are ours - and ours alone - to make.
But even that’s far from a sure thing
- philosophers and thinkers have been
debating whether or not we truly have
free will ever since some guy in a toga
first wondered why on earth he drank
that third flagon of wine last night.
Don’t worry, I’m not going to open that
philosophical can of worms here - I have
another whole video dedicated to the topic of
free will - but suffice to say humans are quite
attached to the notion of being autonomous
beings that get to choose their path in life,
and it’s not hard to see why. To believe the
opposite is to accept that our futures have
already been laid out before us, and that
we’re mere NPCs rather than active players.
You might even say we’d be no better than
zombies, which would actually be quite
handy because then I could casually segue into
the topic of today’s video, real-life zombies.
Now, if you’re going to be a scientific wet
blanket and declare that there are no such
things as zombies, I suggest you visit Ikea
on a Saturday afternoon and see for yourself.
Pay close attention to the faces of men aimlessly
pushing trolleys, nodding and smiling when asked
whether they prefer the SKOGSKORN scatter cushion
or the TUVSÄV. Notice the emptiness in their eyes,
their vacant expressions, and the way they follow
the arrows of flatpack doom as if slaves to some
unseen force. Admittedly that force is probably
the promise of Swedish meatballs and a slice of
Daim cake rather than the chance to feast
on the brains of the living, but still.
Of course, it isn’t just really big Scandinavian
furniture shops that have the power to turn
living beings into mindless zombies - that
utter sadist Mother Nature is pretty good
at it too. Because real life zombies are
surprisingly common in the natural world.
Take, for example, Plesiometa argyra.
This poor spider is routinely chosen to play an
unwitting and unhappy support role raising the
young of a certain parasitic wasp who’s breeding
habits read like something out of a horror film.
The wasp starts by paralysing the spider
with a single sting before laying her larvae
on the surface of its body. Along
with the unwanted babysitting gig,
the spider receives another sinister
surprise - brand-new biological coding.
The wasp’s larvae begin to grow, sucking on the
spider’s bodily fluids through tiny puncture
holes they make in its abdomen. To begin with,
the spider basically just goes about its regular
spidery business as if a host of tiny parasites
aren’t making milkshake out of its insides.
But after two weeks, something changes.
Through a mechanism we still don’t understand,
the spider will suddenly stop
tending to its large circular web,
and will instead feel compelled to craft a
small, sturdy platform unlike any web it’s
ever woven. The spider will spend the last night
of its life on this crazed construction project,
and its reward for finishing is to be eaten alive
by the hungry larvae hanging out on its abdomen.
With that final nutritious meal in their
bellies, the larvae will begin spinning
their cocoons, which they neatly hang
from their bespoke spiderweb scaffold.
Another real-life zombie is the woodlouse, also
known as the pill bug, a common household critter
with a fatal fetish for faeces. This little poo
nibbler has a particular thing for bird droppings,
including those deposited by starlings.
Unfortunately for the pill bug, starling
digestive tracts often carry a parasite that’s far
more dangerous to the bug than it is to the bird.
Once safely ensconced inside the pill bug, the
parasite seizes control. To complete its life
cycle, it needs to make its way back inside a
starling, and so it compels the woodlouse to seek
out the most exposed location it can find. Nothing
is as tantalising to starling tastebuds as a pill
bug out in the open dancing the macarena, so the
insect is soon gobbled up, and the parasite goes
back to colonising the gut of its original host.
Clever. Disgusting and horrifying, but clever.
The green-banded broodsac, uses similar poo-based
tactics, only this time it’s a species of snail
that eats the bird’s faeces. It’s well known that
snails are absolutely terrible at the macarena,
so the broodsac has another way of attracting
the interest of the local bird population - it
grows directly into the snail’s eyestalks,
where it begins to throb and pulsate,
doing a surprisingly good impression of
a catapilar. Before you can say ‘Simple
Simon,’ in swoops a bird to gobble up the
snail… and the broodsac along with it.
As horrific as all these examples are,
nothing strikes as much undead fear as fungi.
The natural world is made up of multiple
kingdoms, with the most well-known being Plants,
Animals and Narnia. Fungi, which include yeasts,
moulds, and mushrooms, have a kingdom all to
themselves and judging by the name, it’s
where you want to go to have a good time.
There are, of course, many different types
of fungi that do many different things,
including entomopathogenic fungi,
that infect (and often kill) insects.
One such fungus is Beauveria bassiana that
can be found growing in soils all over the
world. It infects insects and other arthropods by
penetrating their exoskeletons and growing inside
them, killing them within a few days. If that was
all this fatal fungus did I’d consider it to be
pretty bloody rude, but no. Beauveria bassiana
then proceeds to colonise the poor insect’s
corpse, its spores appearing all over the dead
body before drifting off into the air in search
of more stuff to murder. Beauveria bassiana is
so good at wiping out certain types of insects
it’s actually used as a biological insecticide to
control bugs like termites, aphids, and beetles.
It’s safe to say Beauveria bassiana behaves
brutally, but as far as Entomopathogenic fungi
go it’s arguably one of the friendlier
ones. A particular genus of fungi known
as cordyceps found worldwide in tropical and
temperate regions has a very particular skill:
it doesn’t just kill its hosts, it first releases
chemicals into their brains, taking control of
their bodies and turning them into automatons.
No wonder it’s known as ‘zombie fungi’. No one
knows exactly how many cordyceps species there
are, but there are at least 600, and most target
a single species of insect - anything from
butterflies to dragonflies and cockroaches.
Ophiocordyceps curculionum attacks weevils in
Central and South America. Ophiocordyceps sinensis
kills caterpillars up in the Himalayas. And
ophiocordyceps humbertii infects wasps in Brazil,
causing them to land on a leaf or branch
and bite down into it before passing away.
This peculiar behaviour is also seen in the
effects of the ophiocordyceps unilateralis,
probably the most famous of the cordyceps
fungi and scourge of ants across the globe.
Like its fellow zombie fungi, unilateralis
gets inside its victim using special enzymes
that dissolve chitin, the fibrous substance
that makes up most arthropod exoskeletons.
Once inside, the fungus takes control of the
ant’s brain, making it climb high into a tree
where it bites down on a leaf and pops its six
tiny clogs. Soon, the fungus begins to bloom,
growing out through the ant’s exoskeleton into
balls of spores that burst and shower down on
all the ants scurrying across the forest floor
below, starting the process all over again.
It’s a terrifying mode of operation,
but it’s also very successful,
because cordyceps have been playing this game for
a very very long time. Fossil records show zombie
ants controlled by cordyceps-like fungus were
taking their last bite into a leaf at least 48
million years ago. Other researchers have found
a fungus-infected insect stuck in amber that
goes back more than 100 million years. Part of the
reason for this success is fungi’s adaptability.
Scientists recently discovered that ants are
sometimes colonised by more than one species of
cordyceps. Originally it looked like the two
different parasites were living in harmony,
but further research suggests that this
is probably an example of hyperparasitism,
a situation in which one parasite becomes infected
by another. Remember I said earlier that fungi eat
into insect’s bodies by dissolving the chitin
in their exoskeletons? Well, guess what also
contains plenty of chitin? Fungi! So, in another
weird turn, fungi are practically designed to
infect each other, which is why some cordyceps
cannibals specialise in attacking other cordyceps.
So, we’re talking about a hyper-adaptable
organism that can colonise something thousands
of times bigger than it, taking over its mind and
forcing it into some form of ritualistic suicide.
By now there should only be
one question on your mind…
but don’t worry, there’s no reason to
believe humans can be infected by an as
yet undiscovered fungus and turned into
real life Clickers from The Last of Us.
In fact, it’s kind of the opposite - we may be
able to use these fatal fungi to our advantage.
Cordyceps fungi contain a chemical called
cordycepin that, in biological organisms,
switches on a cellular protein called AMPK.
And it turns out AMPK is pretty powerful stuff.
Initial tests suggest drugs that trigger AMPK
production in our bodies are able to reverse
some types of diabetes and cancer, limit
heart disease, and even make us live longer.
Now scientists think they’ve found a way to grow
cordyceps fungi effectively in laboratories,
potentially opening up the way for new
anti-viral and cancer-fighting wonder
drugs based on cordycepin. Of course, it might
be a hard pill to swallow when you know the
medicine you’re taking is made from a zombie
fungus. Then again, maybe it’ll grow on you.
Thanks for watching.